TOP ! On sait que j'existe mais on ne sait pas où je me trouve ?
*bruit du buzzer*
L'Atlantide ! Heu nan ! Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès !
On sait que j'existe mais on ne sais pas vraiment à quoi je sers ?
*bruit du buzzer*
Le conseil de sécurité de l'ONU ! Heu... Nicolas Dupont-Aignan !
On ne cite jamais mon nom ?
*bruit du buzzer*
VOLDEMORT !
Voldemort... non.
On sait que j'existe mais on ne parle pas de moi dans les livres d'école ? Je suis ! JE SUIS !
*bruit du buzzer*
LE CLITORIS !
AH ! OUAI OUAI OUAI OUAI OUAI OUAI OUAI !
On en parle ni dans les manuels scolaires, ni dans les livres qui expliquent le corps humain aux enfants.
Et à vrai dire, on en parle pas beaucoup aux adultes non plus...
Tiens, toi Romain, tu sais ce que c'est le clitoris ?
Beh non.
Sérieux ?!
J'ai pas fait LATIN au collège moi.
Ok.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il a bien pu faire le clitoris pour mériter au mieux une telle indifférence ? Au pire un tel mépris ?
Bon, on va en parler un peu plus tard mais commençons par le début
sinon on va me reprocher de faire des titres putaCLIT.
Alors le clitoris c'est quoi ? C'est où ?
Ce que je vous propose c'est une petite visite guidée.
Et beh un clitoris, c'est ça !
Enfin, c'est par là.
On va jouer à Où est Charlie.
Alors, vous l'avez ?
Ici ?
Nan, ça c'est le trou du caca, l'anus.
Par lààà...
Non plus, ça c'est le vagin hein.
Là ?
Nan, là non plus, c'est le méat urinaire, le trou du pipi.
Alors par là ?
Nan, ça c'est Jul, je sais pas ce qu'il fout là.
Nan, le clitoris, il se trouve...
ICI !
Tout en haut de la vulve !
Enfin, là, c'est juste ce qu'on voit de l'extérieur, c'est-à-dire,
le capuchon, qu'on appelle en réalité le prépuce.
C'est un petit repli de peau qui recouvre l'autre partie externe du clitoris - le fameux petit bouton,
qui s'appelle en réalité lui, le gland.
Et ouai, c'est la même structure et les mêmes mots pour les deux sexes.
D'ailleurs, avant la douzième semaine de grossesse tout le monde à le même tubercule génital.
Ce n'est qu'après qu'il se développe en organe masculin
ou en organe féminin.
C'est pour ça qu'avant, on ne peut pas déterminer le sexe du bébé à l'échographie.
Bref, la partie externe du clitoris se situe tout en haut de la vulve donc juste au-dessus du méat urinaire.
Sa taille et sa forme varient d'une personne à l'autre
comme plein d'autres organes genre les oreilles, le nez, etc...
Mais ça ce n'est que la partie émerger de l'iceberg !
Ne faisons pas durer le suspens plus longtemps, en réalité, un clitoris, ça ressemble...
...à ça.
Wouuuhhiiiii !
Hop là ! Voilà.
Un clitoris c'est tout ça !
L'organe complet mesure une bonne dizaine de centimètres, donc là tout en haut, c'est le gland donc
mais tout le reste est à l'intérieur...
Le coude là juste après le gland, et beh en réalité c'est pas un coude ça s'appelle le genou.
Me demandez pas pourquoi, c'est comme ça.
Les deux grands trucs là qui ressemble à l'os du poulet pour faire un vœu
ce sont les racines ou piliers du clitoris. Ce sont des corps caverneux.
Et les deux bulbes juste en dessous ce sont des corps spongieux
qui sont placés de chaque côté du conduit du vagin.
Avec l'excitation sexuelle l'ensemble se gorge de sang ce qui provoque une érection aussi bien
à l'intérieur qu'à l’extérieur.
-Pub pour yaourt- Ce qu'il fait à l'intérieur, se voit à l'extérieur
Le clitoris est extrêmement innervé, beaucoup plus que le vagin et beaucoup plus que le pénis
mais bon, ça c'est pas le sujet du jour.
C'est donc un organe très sensible et très réactif et c'est surtout la porte d'entrée n°1 vers l'orgasme
pour celles qui ont la chance de pouvoir en avoir, ce qui n'est malheureusement pas le cas de tout le monde.
L'orgasme peut être atteint par stimulation directe de la partie externe ; vous voyez à peu près comment on fait...
mais aussi par stimulation indirecte des parties internes pendant la pénétration vaginale.
Alors avant que vous me posiez la question, non, le clitoris et le point G: c'est pas la même chose.
Mais ça, on en reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo.
Enfin, si ça vous intéresse hein, je sais pas.
Dites-moi dans les commentaires.
Bon et alors, c'est quoi le problème avec le clitoris ?
Pourquoi on le connait si mal ?
Le problème du clitoris, c'est sans doute pourtant, ce qui fait sa force !
C'est le seul organe dont la seule fonction est le plaisir.
Et le plaisir, c'est sale apparemment.
D'ailleurs vous savez comment on appelle le nerf qui innerve les organes génitaux ?
Le nerf honteux.
Pourtant c'est plutôt sympa le plaisir nan ? Enfin je veux dire, ça fait plaisir !
Beh du coup c'est quoi le problème ? Pourquoi personne parle du clitoris ? C'est pas important le plaisir ?
Ça sert à rien ?
Beeeeh... Ca sert à quoi ?
Ah, bonne question.
D'abord le clitoris c'est le meilleur ami des préliminaires
qui sont eux-mêmes les meilleurs potes d'un rapport sexuel harmonieux.
Donc c'est important.
Bon pour l'utilité du plaisir en tant que tel ?
Beh disons que manifestement quand on a été conçu,
l'ingénieur s'est demandé comment nous inciter à satisfaire nos besoins vitaux.
Pour tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de notre corps
comme la respiration, la fonction cardiaque et plein d'autres fonctions vitales,
l'ingénieur il s'est pas fait chier, il a tout mis sur pilote automatique et
il a tout relié au système nerveux autonome qui gère tout ça sans qu'on ai besoin de s'en occuper.
Mais pour tous ce qui nécessite une action volontaire extérieure au corps, il a fallu trouver un truc.
Créer un besoin bien sur, le désir en l’occurrence, mais apparemment ça suffisait pas.
C'est à ce moment-là que le plaisir a été mis au point. Pour récompenser la satisfaction d'un besoin vital
c'est-à-dire, un de ceux qui sont indispensables à notre survie ou à celle de notre espèce.
Genre boire, manger, ou copuler.
Ça fonctionne notamment grâce à des substances comme la dopamine ou les endorphines
dont on a déjà parler respectivement dans les vidéos sur le cannabis et la masturbation.
Mais bon là on parler de la V1 [version 1] depuis on a pas mal été upgradé [améliorés]
et disons qu'on utilise plus le plaisir sexuel uniquement pour la reproduction.
Et si y'en a qui dise que c'est mal, demandez-leurs ce qu'ils boivent et ce qu'ils mangent
comme ça, juste pour voir.
Il se trouve que ce qui caractérise l'humanité et qui la différencie du reste du monde animal
c'est de faire des choses qui ne sont pas absolument indispensable à la survie.
Ce qui ne les empêche pas d'être indispensable à la vie tout court hein,
bon en tout cas à l’épanouissement personnel.
Rire par exemple, ça sert à rien.
La musique et toutes les autres formes d'art, pareil.
Se faire du bien de manière générale, biologiquement parlant on peut survivre sans.
Mais on peut pas vivre sans, on est d'accord ?
Voilà donc, le plaisir, c'est du sérieux.
Bon, on va pas se voiler la face, l'autre problème du clitoris, c'est que c'est l'organe du plaisir féminin.
Et que le plaisir féminin, il a longtemps été au mieux ignoré, au pire diabolisé.
C'est la raison pour laquelle on se retrouve avec un certain nombre de femmes
qui connaissent mal leur corps et je parle même pas des hommes.
Et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle dans une tout autre mesure,
aujourd'hui encore on parle de 200 millions de femmes excisées dans le monde.
Avec chaque années 3 millions de jeunes filles qui subissent cette mutilation génitale
qui consiste à retirer le clitoris et les petites lèvres, voire les grandes lèvres.
Juste à cause de cette idée que le plaisir féminin c'est mal.
Une campagne de lutte contre l'excision a été lancée par une association
dont vous trouverez le lien dans la description de cette vidéo parce que oui,
ça existe aussi en Europe et même en France.
Avant de se quitter, retenez une chose, que vous soyez une femme ou un homme,
apprendre à mieux connaitre le clitoris, ça ne peut être que bénéfique.
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo !
D'ici là, apprenez à vous connaitre et à connaitre les autres, respectez-vous et respectez les autres,
mettez-vous bien et surtout,
portez-vous bien !